vous remarquez une petite pause est
plutôt un détour plutôt qu'une pause
vers genève on va retrouver notre envoyé
spécial olivier de care en fait
qu'olivier de carreaux fait qu'ils se
trouvent avec guy mettan journaliste
également député au grand conseil de
genève
n'est ce pas une île et s'appelle russie
occident une bière de milan oui
effectivement
stéphanie je suis avec guy mettan
journalistes suisses vous le visent et
ancien directeur du club de spis de la
presse
parce que finalement et bien il y avait
aussi un troisième acteur aujourd'hui 1
c'est la suisse genève qui a accueilli
cette rencontre qui a mis un dispositif
de sécurité impressionnant qui a
d'ailleurs très bien fonctionné on peut
le dire ce soir
alors dis mais tant qu est ce que la
suisse finalement retiens de cette
rencontre ce soir aura su c'est
évidemment une satisfaction parce
qu'avant un gros stress pendant ces
quinze derniers jours pour justement
préparer ce sommet puis quand vous le
savez les américains sont extrêmement
pointilleux en matière de sécurité donc
depuis 15 jours il ya des centaines de
gens des services secrets services de
différents services de sécurité qui
repère en ville qu'ils fouillent dans
tous les recoins justement pour éviter
des problèmes on peut les comprendre
mais pour la suisse c'était un vrai défi
que de réussir organiser ce sommet pour
voir que c'est parfaitement raison
des anglais et qu'en plus certains
résultats semblent avoir été obtenues
donc effectivement pour notre pays c'est
une satisfaction mais ça vient couronner
les anciens sommet qu'avaient eu lieu
par exemple en 1985 autres régaler
gorbatchev donc ça qu'une suite pour
nous deux organisée dans l'organisation
de ses sommets depuis 1815
la suisse a le statut de pays neutre ce
soir comment est ce que les journalistes
notamment ont tout observer cette
rencontre qu'est ce qu'il en ressort
la suisse est un pays neutre mais
malheureusement la presse us n'est pas
toujours aussi neutre que
personnellement je le souhaiterais parce
qu'elle est très biaisée souvent elle
est souvent tronqué en faveur de des
états unis de l'otan et des pays
européens est souvent assez russophobe
dans ses choix dans le choix de ses
experts et aussi dans ses éditoriaux
mais je dois dire que la couverture
aujourd'hui a été très correct ça à
corriger un tout petit peu les
présentations de ces jours précédents et
puis j'ai observé effectivement suivi
les débats sur les différentes chaînes
pendant toute la journée
est ce qu'on peut dire ce soir c'est
avantage poutine pendant la conférence
de presse le président russe a vraiment
dominé son sujet d'abord on voit qu a
pas eu de table où beaucoup de sujets
ont été abordés au cours de cette
rencontre
gemma désarmement pour l'ukraine
c'est évoqué l' échange de prisonniers
rétablissement des ambassades donc on
voit que dans les discussions tout a pu
être abordé ce qui est un bon signe
elle présente à elle a d'ailleurs
confirmé mais on voit pendant la
conférence de presse dans les
commentaires que autour des mêmes
collègues américains étaient déçus au
fond de la prestation du président byden
est bon ça montre que le président russe
dire un petit peu près davantage au fond
l'administration américaine n'avait pas
voulu un d'une conférence de presse
commune ce soir à l'issue de la
rencontre ça a été une erreur finalement
à mon avis ça a été une erreur j'avais
cru effectivement bon de ne pas faire de
conférence de presse conjointe j'imagine
pour pâques donnait trop davantage à
monsieur poutine pendant cette
conférence est en réalité monsieur
poutine ayant parlé pendant 50 minutes
au préalable répondu avec une maestria
effectivement un contrôle de lui-même
très grand pas à toutes les questions
même délicate et embarrassante qui lui
ont été posées président byden
d'ailleurs a réagi plus tard parce qu'il
a il a pris 20 minutes pour analyser ce
qu'avait dit monsieur poutine pour
répondre ensuite qu'il se mettait dans
la position de celui qui devait répondre
à son prédécesseur ce qui n'est jamais
bon dans la communication en plus
brottes détails techniques puisque ce
sont les américains qui ont choisi le
lieu de la conférence mais l'avait le
soleil à contre jour ce qui fait qu'il
était même un petit peu desservi par par
le choix que les américains eux-mêmes
faire pour cette le choix du lieu qu'ils
avaient eux-mêmes peu pour cette
conférence
et personnellement j'en suis très
heureux parce que je disais le
déferlement de la propagande anti russe
dans les médias occidentaux étaient si
forts avant ce sommet que je pense que
grâce au président poutine on a pu
rétablir un tout petit peu mieux les
choses que mieux faire comprendre au
fond les préoccupations de la russie au
reste du monde parce que finalement
elles ont à peine à être exprimées à
peine en tout cas exprimé dans les
médias
et puis des décisions concrètes entre
les deux pays puisque les ambassadeurs
vont pouvoir retourner dans les
capitales des deux puissances est
également le président suisse a déclaré
que vladimir poutine lors d'une réunion
avec lui avait déclaré la nécessité de
coopérer au développement donc il y a eu
finalement aussi pour la suisse des
déclarations concrète ce soir suivant
notre président et notre ministère des
affaires étrangères ont rencontré
monsieur poutine et monsieur lavera ils
ont surtout évoqué des questions
économiques
le soutien aux entreprises russes qui
entre eux précise pardon qui
investissent en russie vous savez qu'à
genève c'est un centre extrêmement
important pour le commerce pour trading
des matières premières l'essentiel du
pétrole et du gaz russe se négocie
messieurs venez donc c'est une place
importante aussi pour la russie et la
suisse figure au top ten dans la
classement des dix premiers
investisseurs étrangers en russie
d'aucun des liens économiques sont
effectivement importante nous deux
merci beaucoup d'avoir accompagné ce
soir ici à genève je le rappelle vous
êtes journaliste suisse ancien directeur
du club suisse de la presse notamment
voilà stéphanie la suisse 1 qui a réussi
son pari finalement d'accueillir au
mieux ce sommet entre joe biden et
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui